أصدرت إدارة شرطة لويزفيل كنتاكي متروبوليتان
لقطات للشرطة والمارة من إطلاق النار في
أولد ناشونال بانك يوم الاثنين
توقف هنا احتياطيًا احتياطيًا احتياطيًا هنا ،
الفيديو الأول هو من الضابط نيكولاس
ويلتس بكاميرا الجسم ويظهر ويلت
والضابط كوري جالواي يصلون إلى
تم إطلاق رصاصتين في المشهد ثم خرج الاثنان
من سيارتهما واقتربا من المبنى
[موسيقى]
بعد
عنابر
الفيديو الثاني من كاميرا جسم جالواي
عندما اقترب الضباط من
المبنى ، يمكن سماع المزيد من الطلقات وشوهد
غالاوي وهو يسقط على الأرض
إنه يركض على الدرجات ويختبئ
خلف زارع بالقرب من الشارع
رائع
[موسيقى]
الله ليس لديه زاوية أعتقد
أنني نزلت ، أعتقد أنه
ميت الآن ، أنزله أسفل
السلالم
في النهاية يستطيع جالواي أن  شاهد وأطلق
النار على المسلح
ثم اقترب من المبنى وركض
أمام ويلت الذي أصيب بجروح خطيرة من قبل
المسلح كونور سمك الحفش البالغ من العمر 25 عامًا ،
نعم ، أشتبه في أن الضابط ،
هاه ،
ادخل الضابط جالواي إلى
المبنى وشوهدت جثة سمك الحفش على
الأرض
كما رأيت  في هذا الفيديو
كان مذهلاً تمامًا ، إنه أمر مأساوي ،
لكن من المدهش تمامًا أن
هناك عددًا قليلاً فقط من الأشخاص في هذا
البلد يستطيعون فعل ما فعلوه.
قتل خمسة أشخاص على يد المسلح وأصيب
ثمانية آخرون بما في ذلك
الضابط المبتدئ ويلت الذي كان في
حالة حرجة مع إصابة  جرح طلق ناري لرئيس سمك
الحفش كان موظفًا بدوام كامل في
البنك لمدة عامين تقريبًا وفقًا
لملفه الشخصي على LinkedIn وفقًا
لمصدر تطبيق القانون ، تم إخطاره
بأنه سيُطرد ، لكن
عمدة لويزفيل وصف هذا الادعاء بأنه
غير دقيق بناءً على  المعلومات
المعطاة له من مسؤول في البنك